do you think that you were so hungry for
success and power and you would get
insanely jealous if let's say Diane
Sawyer got the interview with uh Nixon
instead of you what was that Obsession
to get everything and do everything
um I don't think it was an obsession as
as much as it was a need financially and
otherwise
when I wrote in my book audition I
talked very personally about my family
and my father who had been in Show
Business and and your father owned clubs
he owned great nightclubs called the
Latin quarter in New York and Boston and
Florida and we lived in penthouses and
and he was an entrepreneur and then he
lost everything everything right you
went from great wealth to Great poverty
so most men
go through jobs they hate because I have
to work support themselves support them
families right my friends didn't have to
work I did so it began with that with
with having to do it from losing
everything from losing everything I
always felt that I was on the outside
looking in
and it was a way of being you never felt
successful
um well in the early days it was very
hard for a woman and and it was very
hard to get a job or to be accepted when
I was first on the Today Show uh the the
host who came on the program after Hugh
Downs would not let me do any of the
serious hard news questions
that was a man named Frank McGee went
all the way up to the to the president
of NBC and it was a one time that I
really fought the Battle and the
decision was that I could come in after
the he had asked three questions I could
come in for the fourth so it wasn't
Obsession as much as it was hey I want
to work did you also feel like an
outsider because when you were growing
up you you talk about this your sister
was disabled yes and the other kids made
fun of you because of her true so was
that the reason also how would I think
there was that I think there was the
fact that I went to three different high
schools in four years because my father
kept opening these different nightclubs
and moved and I went from Boston to
Florida Florida to New York I didn't
know how to dress the way the New York
girls did and I felt that I wasn't
Outsider I had did your sister is your
sister still alive no when did you lose
her
um she died of ovarian cancer about I
have to think because I've sort of tried
to block it out something like 15 18
years ago so was that devastating to you
were you close with her all those years
or did you I oh it's a whole I write so
much about it in the book I wanted to
call the book sister because she was the
most important influence in my life but
were you ashamed of her I was sometimes
ashamed of her I loved her I felt guilty
that you had the brains and the looks
and the whole thing and she didn't get
any of the gifts she also resented the
fact that I couldn't join the Girl
Scouts because Jackie didn't join the
Girl Scouts by the way I I didn't have a
birthday party because Jackie didn't
have a birthday party I named my baby
Jackie because I wanted my sister to
feel that she too had a baby what it
gave me and and what it has helped in
interviews
first of all because of my father's
business because I met so many
celebrities of Frank Sinatra Frank
Sinatra hung out in your father's Club
he worked there I have never been in awe
of celebrities but the other thing is
because of my sister I think I have an
understanding and a compassion that I
might not have I think it has helped
I I think it has helped in the
interviews I think it's made me a better
you have more empathy but you had to
take care of her your whole life yes but
that's that's part of my life that's
part of the fabric of my life
foreign